let's jump to this uh very tim
pool-esque story from the daily mail
half of americans expect a second civil
war within years more than 40 agree with
great replacement theory and nearly a
fifth expect they will choose to bring a
gun to a violent political what route
alarming poll shows how do you poll that
that's both call a thousand people and
be like do you plan on bringing a gun to
a political event like yes i do okay
indeed i recommend against that
half of americans expect to see a second
civil war within years and nearly a
fifth
say they could one day be toting guns at
a political face off themselves
researchers at the university of
california davis uncovered worrying
levels of alienation mistrust and a
growing tendency to turn violence in
their recently conducted survey of 8620
adults that's a huge sample size how
many yeah 8 620
that's like four times what's considered
a good number let me tell you why i
think it's worse than people realize
because when i call when i'm talking to
a lawyer they say pick your jurisdiction
based on which president appointed them
and i'm like okay that's not a tenable
circumstance
you can't have
a country where this this district judge
is abiding this one's trump so what's
your case for and against okay then go
to the trump one
if it's it's like that juror
and the bannon thing is that i don't
care what he says because of who he
affiliates with it doesn't matter if
you're a conservative and you're in dc
under on trial locked up
if you're if you're a liberal on trial
now you're fine they'll release you
what's the great replacement thing
they're talking about
it depends on depends on who you ask but
there's it's basically that immigration
is displacing uh natural born americans
and then there's the white nationalist
version so like the left will say it's
always the idea that white people are
being displaced by brown people but many
people who are talking about immigration
might just say it's
natural born citizens being replaced by
yeah foreign citizens i think the
argument on the from the left you know
is that over time people of color will
will will get married to and have
children with people of not color if
that's the point we're all color but
like whatever the people of
european ancestry will get with people
from south america or whatever and then
their children will be mixed that's that
kind of replacement not that someone's
going to come in from south america and
then you're going to be unemployed and
no longer be participating in society
that's the white nationalist fear of
replacement it could be both both known
what's gonna happen what they're saying
is that the white population is
decreasing the white nationalist version
and then minority populations are
increasing the general idea is just
democrats have publicly stated
immigration is a path to political power
for them and it's it's simple leftists
don't have kids
they're more likely to abort and
sterilize so how do they compete with
conservatives who have lots of kids
immigration education but here's a
question yes and a doctrine
for people that say
for people that say there's there's a
civil war
who's leading
how's it split
right
like we don't have the same
you know we don't have north versus
south in this country
was that what countries did most civil
wars don't function that way most civil
wars are like
random factions all over the place that
eventually coalesce when fighting starts
so the u.s is unique in that you had a
union of states break apart and then the
union was like you can't break apart
invaded the south the south you know
teams up or whatever joins forces most
civil wars are like a random faction
with a weird name starts fighting in one
area against the government then other
factions pop up then eventually groups
coalesce and then they're fighting each
other you take a look at like in syria
you had 12 different factions emerge
under isis you know
so one scenario could be
with the united states it very well
could be uh state versus state it could
be like the old civil war
the the scenario that we talked about
quite a bit over the past week is
what happens if
a man and a woman you know get together
and woman gets pregnant in texas where
it's illegal to abort yeah and then at
eight months the woman decides to go to
colorado to abort and the husband or the
husband or boyfriend or whatever is like
i will not allow you to kill my child
now you're gonna have a very serious
conflict because there's no federal
statute and both states are completely
on the other end one saying it's it's
you're killing a child the other saying
no we're not and we're allowed to do it
one saying it's illegal you're saying
it's not
what happens
is is is
is is the guy just gonna sit back and
back guess my my own board child dies in
violation of the law or
are people gonna fight
you know there's actually forget who it
is if you haven't seen it there's
actually a i think they did at the army
war college they did a scenario of what
would happen if america fought against
itself and how the states would go texas
won in their uh in their deal but
for me it's like with everybody shifting
do you
to wherever they're going like blues
moving to red does it ever just get to a
point where it's like okay well i don't
really care that much because you're not
overtly affecting texas
you know what i'm saying like you go to
where you want to live essentially
federalism right and now we're not we're
not
it doesn't really bother me what
happened in maryland doesn't bother me
because i'm in texas or vice versa do
you think that's a stopping point before
it and keeps that from happening do you
think that exacerbates it i i think it
might
be better in the long run federalism and
we talked about this when we had the
progressive feller on talking about
abortion and i was like i don't know
maybe it's better that we do overturn
roe v wade so that the states
who want to live the way they want to
live can and other states
can have their abortion texas can can
ban it but i just don't think the idea
ideology stops there
i don't think someone who truly believes
abortion is murder can sit back and let
people murder babies
and
i don't think the left has a strong
position on abortion at all they're just
tribally for it so that's why i don't
see the left as like
possibly going to invade texas to make
abortion happen they might secretly do
it maybe there's money involved but i do
see it as texas or some other state that
bans abortion as being willing to send
people or even unofficially to stop
abortion right do you take a look at the
first civil war john brown just took it
upon amongst himself what were the
factions there was one country john
brown went started shooting slave owners
in the face
it didn't matter that there was not an
organized faction it happened when the
fighting broke out then organized
factions emerged so maybe that happens
there's a big point maybe you get uh
you're going to see texas and they're
going to be like here's our annual
report 3786
unborn children were were aborted
in a neighboring state and they're going
to be okay this has to stop because we
are morally opposed to the to abortion
and the other state says we're allowed
to do it you can't do anything about it
how long until a new john brown emerges
we've already had violence at abortion
clinics and and vice versa with the left
firebombing pregnancy centers but how
long now with the current situation
until you get a john brown and a
bleeding kansas where he goes into
colorado and just starts getting violent
or something big dif i think the big
difference between abortion and slavery
they're similar but is that slavery is
in plain sight but abortion is like out
of sight out of mind
because when i hear when you see the
ultrasound women they become way less
likely to want to kill the thing
i know it sounds crass but just get past
that part um
and so
you just don't see it and it's like if
you don't see the sewage the sewage
isn't that big of a problem
um
slavery man that drove people insane
people went nuts over that well again
and i would now too i don't like it
it's also the issue though where i can
see what you're saying happens is the
fact that aoc it's it's legal where she
is right and who she represents yep but
then she's still going out there and
making this plea for the case for it to
affect states that are outside of her
jurisdiction and i i mean now that you
break it down that way that's an
explanation for like okay this is why
it's crossing the line because you're
trying to make it happen at a federal
level what we can do at a state level
well let me ask you again how do you
feel about abortion what's your thoughts
on it i don't like it man i don't like
it at all um but do you think it should
be legal do you yeah
so
i'll present present to you this way
when slavery was happening i'm sure
a lot of people said exactly what you
said i don't like it but you know it's
it's legal in those states that's a good
point and then what happens after the
war after the war they're like you
supported them you were defending them
you weren't speaking out
history is written by the victors and
that's why the left likes to say you're
on the wrong side of history because
they firmly believe that when the
fighting's done or whatever they'll be
they'll be the victors
i don't i don't agree with that at all
uh history has a tendency towards the
the expansion of personhood rights so i
don't understand why this would be the
the anomaly here in terms of
well this one time we've decided on you
know these these
unique individuals with dna are not to
be granted personal rights circumstances
are different you know with slavery a
person like
human being living and walking with
abortion they're still dependent to a
certain degree on the mother's body but
that's where viability comes in if the
baby is viable outside the womb this is
the big question
someone in texas a woman can take a
viable child
let's say let's say the scenario with
the man and the woman they get they hook
up they're together at eight months
lemon says i don't want to be with this
guy if i have this kid i'm trapped i'm
gonna go get an abortion the guy says
you don't need to kill it we can do it
we can we can do a induced labor or
c-section right now the baby is viable
and healthy and doesn't need your body
to live
and she goes don't care i'm gonna kill
it
that's where the moral line is drawn not
in like the first week where she
realizes she's pregnant and it's a you
know it's a zygote or whatever and it's
not viable we're talking about a woman
who could say
i could have this baby delivered
but then i'd be responsible for it so
i'd rather flee to colorado to kill it
now you're in
crazy territory see my problem with
everything has also always been the
hypocrisy of it meaning that
if somebody were to murder a pregnant
woman
they're getting charged
with
two counts of murder
so
for me i'm like
i just want everything to be equal right
like if what the rule is the rule is the
rule so if it's if it's two murder if i
kill a pregnant woman then we have then
we're saying that the baby is alive
you can't now turn around you're gonna
put that man or that person in prison
for the rest of their life based on two
counts of murder that was california
right was that yeah peterson yeah but
then you turn around and then when it's
abortion well it's not a life so
how can you do that that's the part that
has always it's always like not set well
that's why i think the
let's just call it the pro-abortion
post-viability side the pro-abortion
side i think they're gonna lose i think
it is a fair assessment to say based on
where history where we've come from and
where we're going
that 50 years from now people will look
back on abortion the way they looked at
it look at slavery but you know what my
issue is i'm actually curious what you
think on this this is the problem that i
had with the overturning of it
is
you know
that branch is supposed to be
independent of political party right
but it absolutely is 100 you guys talked
about this before like they want to now
stack the they want to stack it because
they can't get their policies through
it's still frightening to me that based
on who you put
in those chairs we can have a complete
180
of an interpretation of the foundational
law of the land
simply based on the partisan views of
the person that's supposed to be in the
job so that's that's that's you agreeing
with the supreme court the supreme court
clarence thomas particularly wrote
they keep doing this thing called was it
substantive due process or something
like that this idea that there are some
things that are just so
so uh egregious or whatever that no
amount of due process would would be uh
adequate to deal with the situation that
is to say they're like
the courts should not be allowed to deny
this to a person because they're a
person and it's like
what the supreme court is saying now is
congress
codify it the supreme court does not
decide this
what what so from your perspective
and i i i agree with what you're saying
the supreme court should have never
decided to legislate from the bench
correct here's a challenge though the
country's too divided to actually move
forward on a lot of issues now they just
recently
in the house codified gay marriage and
it's very likely the senate will support
it excellent i don't know if they've
ever done that with interracial marriage
either though but there's a bunch of
issues the supreme court effectively
forces through without the will of the
people without the the electorate which
is kind of crazy when you think about it
the supreme court today said we don't
have the authority to do that clarence
thomas went on to say we should revisit
these other cases to also correct these
errors and oh so what he was essentially
saying there was that we should put this
back to the legislator to make the
decision on it we don't have the
authority or capacity to actually rule
on it but how people reacted was he's
trying to end well i mean the truth of
the matter is no one's i mean in my case
no one explained it like that
yeah you know and that's what we talked
about earlier is like everything's a
second sound bite
so you don't ever actually get any
context behind anything anymore which is
why it's also so damn easy to get
everybody riled up and angry about
what's going on i'd love to to know how
many people think that the supreme court
just made abortion illegal oh yeah an
insane amount
that's wild and insane well and then i
would have people say to me like well
when you like this means that when women
who have a stillborn baby aren't going
to be able to get treated because it's
not considered an abortion when you have
a stillborn baby and you're too far
along and the baby is surgically removed
from your body like that's tragic that's
sad but like it's not actually an
abortion and no one thought it was an
abortion until we suddenly decided that
the supreme court had taken abortion
away from everyone uh i think there was
a such an intense panic i mean i really
want to know how much planned parenthood
fundraised in the last month because
everyone panicked and was like we have
to figure out how to protect this right
which like
i i just think that so much got lost in
translation and if you really believe
that abortion is you know a right that
you need to have i respect that like i
don't have to agree with you but
i think so many
outlets and so many people did a
disservice to everyone around them by
just panicking and encouraging people to
panic and well they use the most extreme
they use
listen both sides are guilty of this
they use the most extreme case of
whatever it is to justify whatever point
it is that they're trying to make right
and for example when the people that
were very uh pro-abortion are like
they're gonna make your rape daughter
give birth
right and i got two i got i'm a girl dad
i got two daughters and
that's that's touches a nerve you know
what i'm saying but that's what we lead
with when the reality is
that's a very small exception to the
rule and in in my knowledge of i can't
wouldn't go put my hand on the bottom
bibles but in my knowledge in most cases
in most states
even with even when it's banned that's
permitted like
this happened like no you don't have to
do it so people make that because they
get everybody riled up over it and it's
just super super easy and nobody ever
steps back and goes okay
what is the actual reality of this how
often does it happen what are the
circumstances for it to happen um but
you have to pick a side
you know and that's what makes it so bad
you can't be like
listen i i don't necessarily support it
i'm kind of the same
look at you and then tim made me feel
bad because he equated it to slavery and
now i feel dirty but um you know it's
i'm the king saying with you like do i
like it no would i am i for it no but at
the same time like
i don't know if i have any
ability to look at you and tell you what
you have to do well let me you know just
thinking of something
um slavery is wrong
uh
however
parents
have
legal control over people under a
certain age true certainly it's not
slavery but they can't tell the kids
you're going to military school they
can't tell the kid you've got to mow the
lawn and the parents have a right to
tell the kid where they live what they
do until they're of the age of majority
and so i was thinking about that because
it's interesting with abortion
there's also a problem and it's when the
life becomes viable when a child becomes
an adult they are a legal entity unto
themselves and they are immediately
severed and free to live their lives as
they see fit children that want to do
that earlier can file for emancipation
they can be emancipated yeah funny
choice of words right i think it's
interesting that
there is an age restriction on when
someone can actually dictate your life
to a certain degree they can't beat you
and things like that and then there's
abortion where i'm actually
more of the traditional pro-choice where
it's like pre-viability i i totally
understand what the road decision was
trying to say
in terms of the privacy of the
individual but also
you know
where the government can step in for
medical procedures the problem i have
with it is it's all elective abortion
like 93 it's all it's just use of using
it as contraception and
just i don't know debauchery and things
like that
but i still fall in a more libertarian
side of like i don't know how the
government should be stepping in but you
get to the point of viability now the
baby can survive on its own
now you should not kill it because you
can just
let it live it can be removed i think i
think 99.9 of americans are with you on
that yeah you know what i'm saying but i
think a lot of times people well i think
people don't think that that i don't
think people think that that's what
happens
at least in the conversations that i've
had with people and i think i have a
mixed bag of friends
those that are forward and those that
aren't a lot of folks are like
but that doesn't ever happen and i i
don't know enough about it to know
whether it does or not but you know
those are the those are the the people
that are are anti-abortion those are the
videos that they show right the the
cartoon animation where you're going in
with their forceps and you're literally
ripping the child apart and pulling them
out everyone shows you the most extreme
and so
for me when i when i look at it it comes
in a thing at the end of the day the way
i feel personally is like
it's all about responsibility right like
no one
told you that you had to have sex right
and then there were all these other
options that you could have done through
it so for me personally if it was just
my body and i was a woman it's like yo
like
if i'm gonna have a kid
then i'm gonna have it where my issue
comes in is with hypocrisy
as a man
i got no say in nothing but i'm
absolutely on the hook for any of the
financial responsibility you talking
about it from a standpoint of the
child's viable the man has no say in it
at all period like i can't say i want to
have a child right
somehow i'm involved in this process but
somehow i'm absolutely not in control of
this process at all but i'm 100
responsible for the outcome the process
is done and people will always use like
deadbeat dads i'm like
that's that's the same thing like gun
laws like there's laws for you to not
buy guns illegally people do it like but
at the end of the day if you go to court
like i got a buddy in texas
and
texas will literally not give
you fit will not give you 50 50 split
the mother gets 51 custody
so on the days of this extra day she
always gets the child wow but he still
has a hundred percent child support yep
and she's a job so that's always been my
thing like
i'm cool with the fact that the dude has
no choice no saying the matter but what
i also would like to see happen is if
the dude says yo cool not my body not my
choice i don't want the kid i am under
no obligation to take care of the kid
the man should have that same right to
in my opinion let's keep it fair thanks
for checking out this clip from timcast
irl come hang out live monday through
friday at 8 pm eastern time super chat
we'll even answer some of your questions
if you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time